何か微寒ですけど 何かご質問など
今の疫血症のですね あのその自分に火をつけて動きを止めるになったというんですが
あの確かにその原罪を抱えますと
自分は何も悪いことをしてないのに
他人が自分の体に入ってきて
それを荒らすと ちょっと腹が立ってくるか
その腹が立つは 怒りがどんどんどんどんエスカレートして
この怒りをする 全く分からないでもないんですけども
そういう怒りのループがどんどんどんどん広がっていって
そのこの七十七番のゲームの時に最初に言ったように病気になっちゃう
そうなった場合にはもう誰も救うことはできない
そうなった時に 自分が
例えば私がそういう似たような状況であって
自分では特に悪いことをしないと思うんだけれども
偉大な怒りのループがそこにいて
非常にその怒り的な その怒り人間になってしまって
それに気がついてはいるんだけども止まらないという場合に
もう仕方がない 勝手って言っても手の施しようもないと言っちゃちょっと大げさですけども
怒り人間になった場合に
これはもうその因果法則によって
まあ何らかの業な結果が来るだろう
それが分かった場合には
もうそれは仕方がないと
自分もやはり地球で言えば地獄に落ちるだろうと
それを起きるのが唯一の対処方法なんでしょうか
それが最初方法じゃないんですよ
なぜかというと まあいつか地獄に落ちるだろうと言って落ちてからどうにもならなくなっちゃいますからね
だからとても危険なんですよ
落ちるだろうと言っても落ち着いてはいけないんです
例えば今の餓鬼の例ありましたね
餓鬼になってから その餓鬼には何もできんでしょうね
たった一つだけの思考で燃えているんだ
苦しいんだというね じゃあそれでね
説法でも聞いてやるぞとかね
これは過去の業だからしょうがない
だからということは不可能になるんですよ
例えば人を殺して逮捕されちゃって
もう有罪になったとする
そのぐらい私は計算していましたから
だからどうなるんですかね
もうどうにもこともできないんですよ
だから一旦この悪業が消した結果
出し始めちゃうと 全面的に抜けられないようにして結果出すんです
そこで私は何も悪いことしていないのに
なんで？という風に考えるでしょうね
それも悪業の働きなんです
なおさら苦しめるんです
なんで私が なんで私がと思わせるんです
なんで私に限ってとか
それも悪業の結果のプログラムの一つなんです
例えばあの 私が壁に石を投げる
投げたらそれ跳ね返ってきて
自分の頭にポシッとぶつけたりする
分かってますから そんな悔しくないんです
自業自得だと言って自分も笑っちゃうし
周りも笑っちゃって済んじゃうんですよ
それ理屈分かると問題になりませんよ
これ理屈さえも分からなくて
なんで私が なんで私がと言うと
あの精神的な苦しみがもっとよっぽど苦しいんですよ
悪が業出すと その結果出すプログラムの中にそれを必ず入ってるんです
だから社会にそれを言わせないことにして
例えば障害で生まれるとかね
障害を持って生まれて
その子は何も悪いことやってないんですよ
生まれる時は障害持っているだけの話で
だからその子は何で私が？とかね
なんで弟が元気で学校に行っても
もうスポーツで何か何とかとってもいるのに
私は走ることもできないでしょうとかね
何でお母さん私は産んだんでしょうかとか
あれやこれやとせちゃうでしょうね
だから精神的にもいじめるという本当は肉体だけの苦しみはそれほどそれほど大きくはないんですよ
まあ足が弱くても車使っちゃえばいいんですよね
しかしその上 性格で屁理屈を叩き込んで
徹底的に精神的に悩ませる
こういういじめられる子供たちの話もやっぱり感じるところあるんですよ
自分がいじめられてるのに
もう一生懸命ごめんなさい
ごめんなさい 何やこれと
というか 読んだところでやっぱりと思ったのは
私はこれは業でどうしようもないんだと
自分が学校でいじめたら蹴っ飛ばしちゃえばいいでしょうに
何やってるのかとかね
ちょこちょこと喧嘩になったってもどうったことはない
先生いい加減にしろよと言うだけで話が終わっちゃうし
なんで喧嘩すんの？って
この人私に臭いと言ったんだよと
だからぶん殴る 先生そんなことで人をぶん殴るなよと
だって だったらなんで臭いって
じゃああんた人に臭いと言うなよ
それで話が終わるでしょうに
だから私はこのいじめっていう言葉は悪いんだけど
子供のふざけてお互いに喧嘩したり
もう言い合ったりするのは
これは自然現象で明るく生きてるという証拠なんですよ
悪業じゃないんです それで臭いと言われたところでごめんなさい
ごめんなさいって言うと言ったら
もうもう日記書いたり書いて
やがて自殺するってことでしょ
なんで自分が被害者なのに
ごめんなさい ごめんなさいって言うんですかね
ものすごく惨めでしょ
だから NHK でそういう番組ありましたけど
いじめられる側は最低親にでもバレないようにしてくれと
もう最悪 もうもう過去の悪業ですよ
そうしか言いようがないんですよ
だからこの問題は解決できません
いじめられたら親だけじゃなくて世間にバラした方がいいでしょう
子供に力がないんだから
大人の世界で無茶苦茶バレていっちゃうと
子供はもう自分はやっぱり気をつけますでしょうに
だから自分をいじめてることは親にバレては欲しくないという
だから親にバレない程度で子供たちが気をつけちゃうと
まあどうぞいじめてくださいってことになるんです
親にバレる なぜ嫌がるかというと
これ人格がなくて 親が学校に行って怒ったりしちゃうと
なおさらかっこ悪いと思ったりすること
だからやっぱり実際のいじめっていうのはどうったことない
臭いとか 臭いという人が本にありましたからね
ボールペンが落ちて そういうこのいじめる子がもうこれ臭い
これこれ誰のもの？とかね
これ触りたくないんだよとかね
そうやってわざわざただふざけてるだけなんですよ
もう それには何かそれなりの何か言い返しすれば
終わるんですけど やられる側がそれで本当にごめんなさい
申し訳ない ごめんなさいとか
だから悪業っていうのはそうやってプログラムして攻撃するんですよ
もう抜けるところはなくなっちゃうんです
だから あの まあどうせもうやがてこんな悪いことしたんだから地獄に落ちるだろうということは
あまりそういうことで落ちすぎてはいけません
このエピソードで地主の突然の逮捕と言っちゃってるんですけども
自分の土地があって そのしつけの悪い人たちに踏み荒らすと
その時に今行ったは怒るけれども
その怒りのループに入ることなくですね
例えばそのお釈迦さん
ブッダのところへ行くんだったら
この道を通って行ってくれとか
ブッダに話をして 私が私が踏み荒らされるんで
そういうことがないようなところに住んでくれとか
そういう対応を取らなかったことが
まあ悪業に落ちていたということで
見せ合うというか  そうですね
ということですね だから理性で考えればそういう選択もありましたね
あるいはいいや この田んぼはとかね
やっぱりその人に田んぼそれしかなかったらそれもできませんだけど
そういう選択もありました
いいや いいや この田んぼはもういいやと
一般のお釈迦様のところに説法を聞きに来るんだから
逃げ出されても仕方がないと
いうふうに考えるというのが
よく言われるその執着を捨てるということ
でしょうね だからでしょうではなくてですよ
だから 執着捨てることやら
喜びを感じることやら
他人に協力することやら
これはもうこの上のない徳であると言っているのは
そういうわけなんです
だから我々にも取るべき態度は着実にあるんですけど
どうも無知 無知専門で
怒り専門で もう欲専門で取ってはいけない態度を取ってしまっちゃうんですよ
だからずっと時間かけて説明したのは楽しみ
初のゴルフは地獄に地獄の苦しみを作るようになってしまう
楽しむ初の音楽がものすごい苦しい世界に結果出しちゃうというね
だからもうスイスイやっちゃった
やっちゃうんですよ スイスイやっちゃったんですけど
結果が出る 知らなかったねとか
そう話には全然ならないんですね
だから行為に結果 行為に結果
これはどうにもならん
だから我々はどうするべきかということがね
だから過去では間違いはいっぱいやったっていうことはもう当たり前
それに悩んだっても もうもうどうにもならんっていうことだから
すぐ今から道を変えるということなんです
だからそれしか方法ないんです
だから前はね いろんな悪いことやっちゃったんですけど
やっぱり地獄には行きませんよと
我は私はと 落ちないようにいろいろプログラム組みますよと言って思考を変えれば
それから明るく頑張っちゃえばいいっていうこと
だから理性っていうのはどうしても必要なんです
私は妄想にすごい悪口言ったのは
この唯一救いの手段は理性なんですよ
妄想するとそこを壊すんだから
海に溺れているし しかし浮き輪と読むんですか
1つはあるんです 理性という
海に落ちたところで 腹が立って
なんで私が海に落ちなくちゃ
これってむちゃくちゃを壊す
潰すのかと 腹が立っても悪口言いながらでも
浮き輪だけはね 船の会社が悪いんだとかね
もう金儲かるために金ばっかり見て整理整頓ちゃんともう安全管理してなかったとかね
あるいはいい加減もうボートを持っていて
別なボートにぶつけちゃったとかね
もう一旦船が壊れて海に落ちた時はいくら思ったっていいんだけど
浮き輪を壊すなよ ということで
人間は失敗したっても
この理性だけはね なくなっちゃうとどうすることもできなくなっちゃうんです
だから妄想にはもう決して甘く見てはいけないんですね
妄想だけは  その理性っていうのは因果法則ってことですか？ 因果を厳密に言えば
因果法則によって考えて行動することですね
いじめられている子は
今自分がいじめられているのは
昔自分がいじめたんだというふうに
もし思うことができたら
それがそのいじめを解決する第一歩になるってことですね
いえ それはならないね
もっと具体的に なんで俺がいじめられなくちゃあかんやとという風に具体的に考えると大丈夫ですよ
過去の業だから超それはアウトなんですよ
できなくなるんです まあいくらか
まあまあ私もいろんな不幸なことに遭いますけど
私は全部過去の業だと言って処理しますけど
で その場合でも問題解決しないというか
できないとかね まあどうせ次も同じことになるんだからっていうことで
これに腹が立っちゃって意味がないんだ
まあいいや 過去の業だからと
しかし 解決できるものだったら潰しちゃいます
解決する 私の場合は だから子供はいじめられる子は
もし過去の業やと思ったら
どうせ子供だからね ろくなことしないと思いますよ
だから一対一で具体的で合理的で
私にも生きる権利があるんだと
あんただけには特権はとんでもないやと言って
ずっとやっぱり生きてみればいいんでしょうに
平等な世界で 民主主義の世界で
誰にでも均等に権利があって
なんでいじめる連中に特別な権利
それはけしからんですね
ですから やっぱり理性っていうのはそういうところで十分ですよ
理性は因果法則ですから
ものすごい難しいと言えば難しいんですよ
しかし 因果法則がわかってない状況では
とっても具体的で合理的で
物事を見る 占いと霊能力者とかはものすごい敬遠する
自分で考えてやりますと
そんなところでなんとかうまくいくとは思いますね
先生 先月の七十のところでちょっと質問があるんですけども
前回の間違った修行をしても
それが法を極めた人の十六分の一にも値しないという
その下のところなんですけども
ここで決まっているテキストの原文でいきますと
ナッガティという字のところのこのナッガティっていうのは
アッガティという値するということは否定と考えてよろしいんでしょうか
カランアッガティっていうのは価値あるということでしょ
テキストではナッガティになってるんですね
七十？ 七十番ですけど
これは否定のナとアッガティがくっついてナッガティになっていると見てよろしいんでしょうか
だからソーラシンカラン
アッガティっていうのはソーリシンカラン
十六分の一の価値があるではなくて
価値がない  否定のナとアガティがくっついてるって考えてよろしいですか
他のテキストなんかに見ますと
そのナがなくてですね
アガティだけになってるテキストもあるんです
そうすると意味が崩れますね
カランアッガティソーリシンと言えば
ソの前にナがあるんですよ
どちらに？ ソの前に  だから
ああ そちらにナあるんだから
そうすると二重の否定になっちゃって
うんうん  意味が取りにくい感じが
やっぱり別に意味がはっきりしていますから
そういう場合は余計にこの分析はしません
だからサーンカタダンマは
私はあんまり違和感感じませんだからね
まあ論理的に厳密にぐちゃぐちゃ考えれば
二つ入っているのは余計ですけどね
でもあまり違和感は感じないんですけどね
もしかするとカランアッガティソーラシンでしょうね
まあだから注釈書でもアッガティになっていて
ちょっともう だから落としてもオンリスは壊れませんね
うん アッガティはね やっぱり相に引っかかってますから
二つも相に絡んでますから
やっぱり否定二つになりますね
これはどういうこと？やっぱりこの他のね
テキストを調べないとね
例えばガンダールダンマパデーヤラね
パーリ語以外のダンマパダとかね
そういうところ調べて
もともとどうどうなったのかというね
調べるして結論は出せませんね
しかし 調べたって意味がない
一応意味はこういう意味だということになってるんだから
カランアッガティではね
決して間違いではないと思います
うーん なんでそうなるのかとね
なんか私は今思い出す
なんかそういう風に自分も暗記したような覚えもないわけじゃないんです
カランアッガティソーラシンとかね
セーマスヨクサンゲね
バーローパンチェートこうやってね
ソーサンカタダンマ カランアッガティ
なんとなく自分がカランアッガティソーラシンという風に勉強したんじゃないかなと
自分一応覚えて暗記して捨て使ってないだけで
今テキストばっかりに頼っているんだから
テキスト文字文字を見ますけどね
普通自分が自分ね まあ頭の中に記録しているデータで考えちゃいます
その場合はソーサンカタダンマ
なんかカランアッガティソーラシン
それを素直に受け取っちゃいます
頭の中だったら そういうことで
このナヒタスは余計だと思います
他のご質問 じゃあ先頭からちょっと変えて
レベルの低い質問で悪いんですけども
霊が見えるとか 霊が霊能者の口を語って我々に語るとかいうのは
私たちがそうだったらいいなという妄想でしかないんでしょうか
そうです 私たちは執着を捨てる
捨てる 未練捨てる いることもあるし
何か言い訳も探してるしね
時々自分の怠けのせいで明るくない
もう暗い思考で子供と喧嘩するわ
旦那と喧嘩するわ もう買い物に行ったらその人になんとかがゴチャゴチャ言ったりすると
家の雰囲気がずっと壊れていくんですよ
それに気づかないで 何かいくら頑張ってもうまく明るくいかないんだとか
なんとかっていう気持ちになったりもする場合
そうすると見事に霊能者が出てきて
霊を除霊してくれたりする
だから我々の結局は我々の期待なんですよ
もう実際に霊が邪魔する時はそう生半可じゃないんです
実際の霊っていうのは
そんなに外へ出すっていうことは難しくないんです
仏教の世界ではね 気にしないしね
気にしないし あんまり邪魔しちゃうとこの野郎何やってるのかと怒っちゃえば出て行っちゃうしね
どうってことはないんですよ
実際はね それにはブッダの世界で生きてる人間でないとできないんです
特に参謀に消えてる人にとってはすごい力ですよ
参謀に消えが入ったらね
だからそういう人々は大体は感じます
ある場合はね 感じたっても全然慈しみの気持ちですから
出て行けと全然ないんです
ああ お前もいるの？っていう感じでいますけど
邪魔じゃお前邪魔するつもりなのかという調子になるだけで
それで終わっちゃいます
まあとにかくもうそういうことはあんまりね
まあ無関心でいた方がいいんです
はい  仕事上のことなんですが
複数人でチームで仕事をしている時に
みんながそれぞれ無知なのでうまくいかない状況が出てきて
みんながそれぞれに対して怒りを持った状態でなんとか乗り越えるっていうのがいつもなんですけれども
その中で怒りが苦しいので
かつそれを人にぶつけてもうまくいかないので
自分の敗北をまあ言ったりとか
うまく条件はうまくいってないので
ディスカッションというのは持たれるんですが
その時に相手のことをなかなか言っても
それは直るわけでもないし
たいし分かってもらえないと思うので
自分のいけないところを出すとすると
でもそれはじゃあ自分で直せるかっていうと
やっぱりその無知のまま解決策を自分で持ってない
自分はそんなうまくいかないことがない時は
割と人がうまくいくなってもカバーができたりするので問題がないんですが
その全体的にうまくいってない時の自分のこの対処の仕方がわからないというか
お手上げ状態になってしまう
その中でせめてその怒り
そのチームの中の怒りだけは無くしたいと思うんですけれども
方法は 2つです  第1正しい方法
いつでもこの無知にリーダーシップをあげているでしょう
世界は説法でずっと説明するでしょう
だから無知にリーダーシップをあげると
いつでも結果は逆になるになってるんです
だからゴルフの例とか余計なことを延々と喋ったのは
もう目すごい冗談的にわかってほしいんですよ
あれはもうとっくに もうスポーツでなく遊びでなくなってるんだからね
逆になってる ですから
この会社の仕事であっても
結局は無知様がもう監督なんですよ
だからむちゃくちゃ結果出さないってことにする
それでもやってる人間が悔しいんだから結果出したいんですよ
だから当然怒りで苦しんだりして結果出すんですけど
やっぱり損の方が多いんですよ
結果出たってもちっぽけな結果にすごいくたくた疲れたということになるんですよ
だから正しい答えは監督
本当にものすごい現実主義者の
すごい論理的な理性のある人は監督にしなくちゃ
いわゆるオーバーオールアドミニストレーションという英語で言いますけど
総合的な管理  でも 上に行けば行くほど抽象的な話が好きなんですよ
こういう時はこういう方法論でやるんだとか
こういうふうなシステムにいきましょうっていったのがついていかない
現実的にトラブル  だからそこは無知でしょう
だから無知だから上に行ってるでしょうね
だから当然無知な人は昇格しますよ
どちらでもリーダーシップを取ろうとするのは無知に決まってます
真ん中にいる人が日本は一番厳しいと思うんですけども
下の人はだからみんなちゃんと仕事をきちんと振らないからだって怒るし
上は真ん中がきちんと管理しないから
だから真ん中にいる人々が理性に基づいで自分で計画
プログラム全部かけて書いて
実行的に だからこの これは教えにくいんですよ
特に公では言いたくないんです
いろんなやり方があるんです
人を管理するやり方っていうのは
で なぜ公で言いにくいかというと
人を管理するのは正しくないんですよ
もう人間らしからんバカもんたちだから
もう猿動物扱いでいいということなんですよ
日光猿軍団だったらどうします？ちゃんと芸やってるでしょ
あれはすごい理性的な管理で猿に芸をしてもらう
だから日本の会社で 社会で
もうみんな猿だと思わない限りはうまくいかないんです
だから猿だと思うためには一人でも人間が必要でしょ
その人がまずどうにもならないっていうのが
でもあの それでも 例えばこの一番下っ腹の社員であっても
理性がある人だったら全く気付かずみんなを管理するんです
これやってくれる？あんたこれやってくれる？とかね
そうなってくると みんなこの
なんとなくわかってないんだけど
うまく仕事言ってると
みんないい気分になって喜んだりする
それは それは正しいやり方なんですよ
いわゆる あの とてもこのラショナルな
何て言いますか administrator
が必要なんですよ プラン
これプランニングがあって
これからプランというのは実行しなくちゃいけないんですね
あれ プランはどんなバカにも書けますよ
頭の中でね 観念的に だからプランというのは
この このプロジェクトの中で
この実践のプロジェクト
別にあるんですよ 実行の計画
それが一番大事なんですよ
私もいろいろ社会のことをやっていた時は
上からもう単なる観念的なプロジェクトをドンと投げるんですね
腹が立つんで いい加減に投げかけたってもね
やるのはこちらではないかと
それでも上に怒ったって意味がないでしょうし
まあいいや もう怒ったっても猿だからっていうことで
もし物事わかっている
大学ですよ 私は上は教授ですからね
そんな程度のことわかるならばね
こんなこと言わないんだと
こんなプロジェクトはね
で 私は一人 では実行の計画はどうなるのかと
いて キーと実行の計画はセルごとに瞬間で切るんです
切ってバラして それでも私に実行できる力がないんだからね
また元に 元の人に渡すんですよ
私の命令聞かない人々もいますからね
時々年上の人にも仕事をさせなくちゃいけない
すごい格の高い人に仕事をさせなくちゃいけない
私がプログラム作ったら
しかし自分では言えないんです
だから前に持っていった人にまた持っていって
実はね これこれこれがこのこの人がやった方がいいんだけど
これこれこれはこのこの人やった方がいいんですけど
この締め切りで どうしましょうかと
やめるかやるかと 言ったら
ああそうね じゃあまあここは私は言ってあげます
これを私は本人に今ちゃんと計画書がありますから
本人の気分が良くて 電話かけて
もしもし何々さん あのね
まあ今これから送りますから
これこれやってくださいとかね
そうすると上の人もいくらか気分がいいし
結局一番下っ端にいる私の
私が糸を引いてます みんなの
それで一つも怒り憎しみなく終わったんです
私がいた場合は 失敗はさせない
ものすごい悔しい失敗しちゃうと
で しかし私にはすごい自信があったんだから
どんな偉い人であっても言いたいことは言う
で 言って怒った じゃあ怒りたければ怒ってくださいと
できればクビにしてください
私をと これはもういくらでもやりませんだからね
向こうは ですからもう
でも人間にはそんなことできないでしょうにね
だからやっぱり一人一人がこの具体的なこの実行のプランっていうのはね
必要ですよ 例えばそちらに任せた仕事あるでしょ
そこはどう実行すればいいかというね
スケジューリングとかプランニングをするのが仕事なので
その期間中ずっとそれをしてたいんですよね
そのある期間の間にもずっとそれをしてるんですよ
その仕事を プランを作るっていう仕事
ただ ずっとプランが変わるので
こっちに振られたプランが
また違うのがどんどんその形を変えたのが出てきて
その人たちはそのプランを作るのが趣味っていうか仕事なので
だったらその会社倒産するようなシステムだよ
どういうことかというと
まずプランが来るでしょ
それやってるとまた変わるでしょ
自分たちは全部仕事を放り出しちゃって
次のプランで実行する
それまた変わってくるでしょ
また今までやった仕事を全部放り出しちゃって
また始まるんです  それだといけないんでって
あるところで上がってくるプランを止めて
個のでとりあえず上げなきゃと思ったんですよ
それ向こうプラン変えるんだったらね
そうすると今度は  会社倒産しますからね
ちゃんとしたコミュニケーションが取れてない
いえいえ 上 会社管理する人々に能力ないということで
だからその場合は普通の社員は
あの 何て言いますか キャプテン
頭狂ってるキャプテンの船には乗らないんです
キャプテンの頭狂ってるんだったら自分一人で自滅しなさいと
船の他の乗り組み員が別な船に仕事をもらうってことになるんですよ
先ほどおっしゃった抽象的なのを具体的なのにしてあげると
彼らは気分がいいので
それをエンドレスにまたやり始めるんですね
さらに良いプランがとか言って
なんかこう で 実際は仕事が上がらないっていうか
だからもう だから上の人クビにするしかない
まあとにかくこのプランが来たら
それは実行プランにすぐきめ細かく砕いて実行しなくちゃいけない
それは大体実行する人がやる範囲になりますけど
プラン作る人の仕事ですよ
本当は あの この建物作る時も同じことがこの建築家プランを作るんだけど
大体中途半端ですよ  建築はものがあるので
その時はこの大工さんたちが定規を持ってますから
そこをちゃんとちゃんと自分で
ITとかコンピューター業界ってものがないので